but so how'd you pursuit pounds easy DS
it hurts yours why would you put this on
the line hey what's going on everybody
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by comedian Jay Pharoah
he's a busy guy but you can catch him in
legends of Chamberlain Heights which
premieres this week on Comedy Central
yes sir Jay how are you I'm usually good
I'm really good with spicy stuff yeah I
mean spicy it's just it's good going in
it's just coming out is my problem
oh my that's always there's always a
second actor to play in this one you
ready to get this going let's get to it
yeah dang
[Music]
[Music]
the first one is sriracha sriracha even
around the block a couple times you know
Samantha no sriracha oh good it is good
as [ __ ] yeah that's just like a good
wing this snagger Michelle Obama she's
done a ton of skits lately from the
stuff that she did with the Miami Heat
carpool karaoke and she seems to be
genuinely funny when she does these
things or at least have better comic
timing than I think you'd see out of a
lot of public figures you know when you
think back on the shoot that you did for
go to college what stands out to you
what do you take away from that um her
like her like point in the camera and
doing this and being like Southside like
swaying her body like she did like this
this snake move and I was like oh that's
dope you gotta watch be et for that she
can actually spit yeah she got bars if
she was like hope like she laid anyone
hurt she one person she walked out and
she had a home studio joint set up and
everything it was really dope I was
really impressed when you look at the
photos do you ever think you know what
that sweater it works in the music video
not so much in the Oval Office there
none of you yes that wishes you could
have worn cooler clothes in the way
that's what they you know what that's
what they instructed me the way I would
never wear that never that outfit looks
like give me a wedgie that's what it
looks like like like dip my head in the
water and give me a swirly like I'd get
my ass whipped over water anywhere else
young Stan that outfit comes with
pokemon cards I looked at that guy he
never looks like he never looks fully
Mexican that dude a beer dick ain't
never does he looks like he looks like a
whistles Ames Steve Carell like with it
with a sombrero I heard you met an
ex-girlfriend on MySpace who is not only
as well did you know that [ __ ] okay not
only a stripper mm-hmm
but also a member of the Bloods gang she
was which of those two things do you
think played a bigger role in the
unraveling of the relationship oh I
think it was just the fact that she
didn't come out tell me it from the
beginning yeah I mean learning these
things about her she told me oh by the
way I'm in a gang oh say what like
that's not by the way [ __ ]
some [ __ ] you tell somebody when you
first meet them that's great that's I'm
talking about you I'm not for reading
this [ __ ] well it's all good you can
cheat oh that's a cheat day my guess is
in every interview that you've ever done
people always want to know about the
celebrity host on Saturday Night Live I
have 10,000 questions what I want to do
is give you four names from the last
couple seasons I just want to get the
first thing that comes to your mind when
you're living with that person for a
week what sort of stands out to you okay
all right Kanye West
I was talking to Kanye West at SNL 40th
and then he's talking for like 10
seconds and after these 10 seconds he's
like all right me and Kim are gonna go
[ __ ] goodbye
I was like wait like like here like now
like is it gonna happen at the 40th my
quizzes where's this footage speed B
maybe and probably probably operating in
a world all of this just just a weird
world of conduct Larry David oh man
fantastic I remember Larry David was
telling me um he couldn't believe that
you could believe my j.b smoove was the
way it was
really how do you do JB smooth like that
that's great that is
I don't know food you don't even know
fool me know what's up boom ha ha ha
it was like that's the baby Tracy Morgan
I gotta know about Tracy Morgan a
beautiful a beautiful soul this comeback
was like really emotional for like
everybody if you just saw him having fun
again it was like I just want to have
fun that's all I wanted was just wanna
have fun again I just want to get out
there can people pregnant my Lady Gaga
Lady Gaga oh hey man I ain't [ __ ] what
the hell happened Lady Gaga she was
great she was very talented he's
freakishly tell fantastic that was the
first time that we did the Kimye sketch
I was the first time we did that she was
playing like a chick from the AppStore
and all this you know yeah and it was
fun she was great - I see always I have
nothing they could say Y angle my mess
of my chest will collaborate he'll know
there's a slight picante that meshes
with the meshes with them as the corn
oil you're in freakish shape and we were
talking about the gym before the show
even started who do you think's in
better shape right now you were Kevin
Hart Oh kick Kevin's eyes he would say
the same thing I betcha he would I
thought Kevin's there's a crossroad not
isn't isn't not our calves my dude he's
in great shape
you know he's got a six-pack you don't
mind like I for the Eagles right but if
you took his the white like don't
stretch it just take what he's got put
it on me it'd only be one AB that's a
fair point I think that's a good that's
a great point as we first saw me that's
when I first lost weight and I was like
skinny he was like no wow it's great to
meet you male you killed it
funny as hell I like what you did Bank
now hit [ __ ] out here back boy Wow we
get forgot I already forgot it I met him
again I saw him again he was like damn
Jake hmm
getting big found your chest too it's
uncomfortable
listen you're too tall I don't like it
man Pete you're scary
BAM you'll scare somebody nobody's gonna
laugh at you because they think you're
gonna whip their ass BAM they also swipe
mango nish to it um mm-hmm
such as blend huh what's a very strictly
grunt oh it hit me right there oh I get
it
little hint all right mmm I'm so many
you know about so you're one of the
great comic Impressionists in the world
right now and you've channeled some of
my dream guests in the past so what I'm
hoping as I can just you know if you'll
humor me hit you with some and then
maybe you review our hot sauce is that
sound good sounds great
DMX what'd you think of the hot sauce um
you know listen Dawg you the only
[ __ ] thing is this you know you know
it doesn't really baby but you know I'm
just trying to be I'm just trying to
clear my vocal cords because it's a lot
of mucus fill uh own accord Burke aye
it's delicious [ __ ]
I love these wings Stephen a Smith what
do you think listen this wing is very
delicious and you know we're reminds me
it's excited not like Tim Duncan who is
not excited who plays the most
fundamental game but he gets the job
done and that's all that's important
these wings
basically have you just water in at the
mouth like you're looking at a bad [ __ ]
quick what what what a heavy ass stuff
yes I don't know and I have your own
arrow Eddie Murphy what do you think of
the wing and what do you think Assizes
name and his sauce is amazing man you
notice I'm trying to figure out why any
hotter than it is though you know I'm
saying juice is this isn't normal to me
you know I like spicy stuff you don't
say you know spice I'm gonna I go to any
clubs I know spiciness Eddie that's what
some people say you know they're like
they expect our hot sauce to be like the
hottest hot sauce but we wanted a good
tasting smooth hot sauce but I think
that's a fair it's very smooth is very
cool smooth hot sauce now if you ask any
shop the same question you would have a
Shannon said it paid like you ever been
with a Mexican
oh my god it doesn't understand you know
sometimes they will take a habanero and
they put it inside of your margarita and
then you wake up and then all your money
goal but you're both empty kind of a net
positive read on that one without uh
Will Smith what do you think this uh you
know what like yo like this is crazy and
I mean like it's a good sauce you know I
like it um you know
Jayden wouldn't like this he was saying
nah because you know I'm saying is you
know it's you know yeah it just tastes
boys ain't off the ball with Daddy you
know but it did so I'm dead ends up this
wing is very delicious huh
it reminds me you know if it gets any
hotter then a tear is gonna come now my
face just like it did in glory because
I'm going through it
ha I love you whoa huh I planned up now
huh that's what you need to tell
everybody who tries to take the milk man
no [ __ ] I feel like I just got yelled
at by Denzel Washington
now we're in the back nine now we're in
the back nine J alright a little back
now missus I get this it is four more
and I'm straight lizard okay maybe you
want to push move I was to where I was
just gonna put it on this one let it sit
a little bit I'm gonna put it on this
one that's idiotic
I'm gonna remember these moments J
mm-hmm Chia
I'll go JZ jaywalking a badger talking
this one I love you Lisa you know
haven't felt this good since you know
the first time it me and Beyonce
fornicated wow that's a huge moment for
yourself but it's whoa now this one got
a little kick in yeah this out of the
game changes home a little you know what
was it like shooting the hotline bling'
spoof with donald trump because he's on
set and he's wailing out lyrics he's
actually doing dance moves and always
wondered was somebody there coaching him
through all that or what was that scene
he owes me every time really every time
he would do something Jay is just what
you want me to do it again you like the
way that I do this do I need to take my
hand and put I know when that hotline
bling we got it fantastic
I can leave was it really like that he
was talking to you about it and I was
like keep doing this [ __ ]
whatever this whatever the hell this is
this is three more wings and I'm sitting
here taking this one time just for DMX
it wasn't even because of the hotness it
was to clear the palate for an
impression I think I'm gonna I think
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make
ya'll find something hotter whoa
that's right [ __ ] I want to talk
about Drake's week for a second just
he's such he's such a nice guy
hey he's Canadian they're nice right the
good that's why every time Drake talks
and when I hear rap I'm like that's not
you
I'll take your [ __ ] [ __ ] I take your
mouth [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't do that
[ __ ] and rely in real life no didn't II
do the after-party at Dave & Buster's
yes was the Dave & Buster's this one
over here on Times Square cos complex
had an employee party at Dave and
Buster's one time I want to know how
they match up well I just see him I just
see
and playing arcade games he was on stage
he was on stage like is everybody having
a good time
yeah and then a [ __ ] fight broke out
in a trying party gonna SNL party yeah a
fight broke out cuz Drake attracts the
ratchets right like that's what he does
so he's throwing this party when you
have people together not corporate and
they had no settings with free alcohol
bars open
hey that mean the tracks are gonna be on
the ground this is a girl fighter guy
fight was a girl fight always a good
old-fashioned tracks were on the ground
in a girl 1 boom boom initial go like
this and a whole join get ripped out a
hit it was on the ground its resting
this moment of silence for the track
everybody be quiet
yeah but she got a ass with now it's
real
mmm-hmm there's getting realer so this
is a part of that show has anybody ever
told you who are you gonna say it look
like you look like a heterosexual
version okay of Neil Patrick Harris love
that that's that's top five that's top
five you know who you look likes to me
don't mike epps told me I look like
Smeagol from Lord of the Rings - hey
that one's ever said to me that's that's
funny though it was adorable funny
that's he said he's like he has nice
eyes that's how he's trying to get his
way out of it I was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me dude but he said you look
like you yeah right - my Louie girl
smooth girl like you can do the
impression yeah we're doing about your
form yeah okay kinda let it right stupid
fat Hobbit fools would there was enough
there was an Hashanah this is a sermon
sermon
stupid fat purple don't blame smuggle in
my love
oh well out through their bodies oh no
rings head dude how many jumps are house
mice Meagles ID badges right thank you
it's terrible okay damn that was right
there's no there's no graceful way to
segue out of that no okay this next part
of the show is called explain that
Graham so we do a deep dive on your
Instagram there's some pictures that we
think are interesting we pull them up
because we need more context that's
something good let's do it this is going
great
Jayde are you having fun i dis just
funny [ __ ] I'm having and we're on the
last two and hey still haven't tapped
out you and reread this is a moment uh
we were in London
uh-oh we didn't go to London to Dover
okay so this is a happenstance pads
crossing to that just happen Y to happen
we got lost it was me and two of my
homeboys we were taking this I was
taking this euro vacation and we ended
up getting lost for three hours we ran
into this promoter we were like we're
from America he was like I'm always in
America I'm hanging out my boy DJ whoo
kid I was like DJ whoo kid he goes on
yeah DJ whoo kid and I was like yeah you
listen to the show he was like yeah and
I was like yo you know Jay Ferrel he was
I here to do it does not a voices and
stuff I said yeah he was like oh [ __ ] so
he invited us to Sergei DC will that's
the club that that was at right Drake
and Rihanna right there that night right
we get to the club they take us back
full treatment
I see Rihanna she was like oh my god
like what are you doing here late don't
you have to lay record late this week
like aren't you are like recording and
Drake was like oh my god dude like what
are you doing here
like this is great dude what are you
doing tomorrow I'm like I'm gonna be in
England here no no you're not you're
you're coming out to the show
I have a show in Manchester I was like
well I can't really
I got it Hotel no dude I'll flag you out
everything will be good
taken care of we'll get you a bus
everything well [ __ ] London yeah
hey so take that invitation yeah we flew
out there we go to the concert there's
drinks they give us our own tour bus
full of groupies I mean full of them no
I mean you will you know the selection
in England you know some of them there's
a bad ones but you know it was a stock
bus it was a stock bus it was our own
personal love them bus he flew us out
there Rihanna was there we were all
hanging out turning up it was one of the
best times I had so this one is mad dog
357 it used to be one of them okay
listen I'm gonna just open this and hand
it to you and I would say to be careful
Jay listen listen Jay I'm not your dad
I'm not I'll tell you do we tell you
what type of person I am Adam I used to
drink hot sauce what I used to drink it
yeah that sounds weird but I used to
drink it it was good for like 20 minutes
and then I can say for yeah I definitely
did oh that church path okay but then
look at where you are now yeah I can
just do this that's a lot whoa whoa whoa
oh yeah I shall say high school that's
cold
well if you're gonna dip I'm gonna do
you're gonna do it too that's you got a
dipping in that's what you just did me
no [ __ ] dip there that's egregious
there we go you ready I'm smiling
I think this [ __ ] is hilarious let's do
it
hmm Oh God cool what we should do pretty
stupid but hmm you know it's hot when
you stop tasting the sauce you're the
one who made us do this oh right and
you're living with the consequences like
it's not I've definitely loved it
oh yeah but go ahead all right so a lot
of your more casual fans might not know
the extent of your music catalog lot of
its comedic some of it's just straight
bars
I mean how do you see yourself you know
because a lot of comedians do rap or
have tried rap and a lot of rappers
sometimes unintentionally are like the
funniest people on the planet where do
you fit in this is what's crazy about
rap and comedy it's very synonymous
setup punchline execution delivery
that's an execution because the spit in
my mouth right now is just intense yeah
it's like the Red Sea uh-huh Cassidy
that's my dude yesterday I sent him that
freedom freestyle dude you heard a
freedom free song
mm-hmm okay so I sent that to him he was
like hey young man
it was a yo man you got bars boy like
don't do that [ __ ] to the man like they
don't understand like they used to that
[ __ ] this is a Cassidy impression
with a lot of hot sauce in the mouth oh
he was saying that I bodied the [ __ ] and
that's the dude I used to look up to the
most cuz he's a nurse's Wow he's dope
Campos a boozes I think Papoose is
lyrical too I love that verse that so
this house kind of like the Grey Goose I
love peplums baby exclusive beat up the
track to bully your brain from very
abusive
this [ __ ] has got caught right here in
my chest it's like right listen I'm
gonna do that dumb [ __ ] no more so no mo
it's funny that you say that uh-huh put
them with spit on my name here we go
so this is Blair's Megadeth sauce with a
liquid rage it's tradition to dab the
last wing around here a week to have the
one before so when I was not just a dad
just dunk hot sauce oh you're playing on
a dad one - [ __ ] oh really doing oh
alright you don't have to if you don't
want to know I'm no no hey laughter all
it is I got a do it I had a feeling that
that's where this was Shu I have to do
it okay your little that's a little
reckless J really that's a little
reckless
nothing good Glock that's a good end
that's going the extra mile oh you let's
Cheers because this is a great one and
for this last question what I'm gonna
tell you is this like your facial
expressions sometimes make me laugh
just as much as your impressions you
have a very expressive face but I'll
tell you this about me I've never lost a
staring contest in my entire life okay
so I'm hoping we can do is take a bite
out of the wing first to blink loses no
holds barred you want to go facials i'ma
go like wait okay I know what you meant
wait but you gotta understand the way
that [ __ ] sounded like when I said it I
knew a medium you you wish you could
just take their parent dad so doesn't
end up a vine that's like the cartoon
bubble that you want to like a race
you're okay so that's I'm gonna do you
wanna stare staring contest
all right ready want to take the bite
that's a staring contest are you right
right
oh no no no wow wow oh [ __ ]
it's all a matter of focus with me
mmm-hmm
let's get the tunnel I just lost him for
a second but kind of back all right bad
Jam this will be very hard to do what
somebody will do that cross eyes you
know what that almost makes you pop god
I don't even know how that happened I
didn't feel like coming you want to do
it it good I'll give you a second so I
do best out of three if I wouldn't let
see brother I'm taking another bite I
don't know if we have to oh we don't
have to okay we don't have to well I
think we have I think we have to listen
I'm with death no listen I can tell that
type of Satan again I can't back down
bah I gotta get on a flight I better get
some bread huh yeah but I won the
singing contest I better win or this is
all this is all for no cuz check this
out this is my one Episode you outdo
this [ __ ] again and again a kid not J
that I need you to host when I go down
my cool [ __ ] nobody's [ __ ] with J I
mean the eyes are totally lubricated I
keep saying looky there you go okay one
more
nothing to you know God Angie
[ __ ] I got an eyelash stigmata limits
damn Hey huh now give this [ __ ] water
alright Jay your first guest is just up
the ante and keep upping the ante then
you beat me two out of three in a
staring contest
I'm totally emasculated on my own show
nothing left to do but just give you the
spotlight the floor is yours
check assault this camera that camera
let the people know what yet going on in
your life make sure you check out
legends that is coming out September the
13th make sure you check that out also
but new mixtape that'll work you know
I've got everybody up there I've got the
producer bounce William he's gonna do it
I've got music so child on the track
I've worked with mooing so trout Oh some
of his stuff um who forgets of what is
new okay also uh what else I got going
on Google ten feral Cougars Rafer Jesus
wow it just hit me all at once
I think the milk brings it out why just
do is just maybe do a biggie impression